the tampa bay buccaneers celebrating
in very unique style due to the pandemic
their championship that was secured
three of the lombardi trophy
by tom brady from one boat to another
i've got no skin in that game it freaked
me out
and i could only imagine
the rescue operation shireen that would
have followed
if that trophy had ended up at the
bottom of the hillsborough river i
assume they bring in the frogmen from
the police department immediately much
like the rescue operation
when flick's tongue was stuck to the
flagpole although then it was the fire
department
i don't think the fire department had
frogmen apparatus you'd have to get the
police department
to go find the trophy and tom brady
would gladly pay the bill but that
that makes me nervous every time i see
it
and i think they trusted tom brady i
guess they trusted tom brady i'm sure
they didn't know
what he was going to do with that
lombardi trophy but yeah i'm like
that was pretty dangerous right there
that thing could have gone in maybe it
was just a replica maybe it wasn't the
real thing right who knows but
it did all those videos man it makes me
want to move back to tampa seeing those
guys in shorts i'm ready to go right now
it's freezing outside
no no we've already established you
can't go back because that's the moment
that the magic ends you bring that with
you
it happened when you were covering the
buccaneers and then you took it to
dallas with you
and they they they love you but they're
fine with you staying in dallas
uh so look i i everything about it
was was fun to see and
yeah tom brady celebrated the way that
most
normal human beings celebrate a major
achievement
it was odd to see him behave like a
normal human being
because this is the guy that we have
come to regard as robotic
to see him stumbling and one of his
friends handles whoever that is
keeping it from being an obvious drunken
episode
it kind of reminded me of weekend at
bernie's the way that they were doing
the walk there
but somebody spiked the avocado ice
cream i mean what can i say
tom's living it up it was ryan griffin
mike that carried him out so they
finally found a use for the third string
quarterback
he did play the part of patrick mahomes
last week right so i guess he has two
uses play the part of patrick mahomes
and carry tom brady out after the
celebration
maybe griffin would have been the guy
they told to go get the lombardi trophy
from the floor
of the hillsborough river if it had
missed the boat but
look you gotta let them have their fun
and then bruce arians
taking shots at the chiefs when
addressing the team afterward and jason
lights saying we're going to bleeping
win this thing again
that confidence that infects every
professional athlete and coach quickly
becomes
hubris right after you've won a
championship because
you've just done it so can we do it
again well hell yeah we just did it
why can't we do it again and now that's
going to be the talk of the offseason
can the buccaneers do it again
will they lure enough new players to
town to
help them get better will they keep
enough of their own free agents aryan
said today they're going to keep chris
godwin and levante david that may be
hard to do if the cap goes down but
hey they're living it up they're loving
the moment they've earned it they're
entitled to it but there's a reason
there hasn't been a repeat champion
since 2003-2004
yeah and i do think mike that free
agents watching that today
are saying hey why not tampa bay why
don't i go there for a one-year deal and
try to win one with tom
if that's you're near the end of the
career why wouldn't you want to go to
tampa i mean all the reasons we've
mentioned no state income tax
it's nice weather in florida you get to
play with tom brady you have a chance to
win a super bowl i mean
all the things you want so i'm sure
there's free agents out there right now
watching this going yes
looks like a pretty good place to go to
me
adrian peterson who has been bouncing
around the nfl in recent years he was
with the vikings all those years then
the saints then the cardinals then
washington last year detroit
he's already said he wants to join tom
brady in tampa
they're going to be turning guys away
there's going to be
veteran players who very much would like
to
get on board the buccaneers boat and win
a super bowl and they're going to have
to say to some of these guys
no thank you no thank you no thank you
and that is a great problem to have
where there's only 53 roster spots
but what you get out of this if you have
these great players
who want to cap their careers with a
championship
they willingly take on backup roles this
is a way to
fill out you know the patriots always
had
through the salary cap that they saved
on contracts like tom brady's
a very robust middle class of veteran
players who would serve as
depth be for example if your left tackle
and right tackle or injured like they
were for the chiefs
the drop off from first string to second
string isn't as great
as it was for the chiefs the patriots
were able to do that
the buccaneers may be to pull that off
this year shireen if you get these
veteran players who are willing to
take less to be part of the magic that
they've captured in tampa bay
yeah and they did it with leonard
fournette they got him in the middle of
the year
in ronald jones with their starting
running back ended up getting hurt
played very little in the postseason
and leonard fournette was a running back
who carried him in the postseason
so you do need that death no question
about it and that's what you get
when you're a guy like tom brady and and
players flock to you
bucks right now as you said yesterday
mike have 31 players
under contract they've got a lot of work
to do this off season to get that roster
field out they do have a little bit of
cap
room we know it's going to go down but
guys are probably going to take less to
go to tampa to play with tom brady
today's celebration created some
memorable
moments top of your head what is the
first
thing that stands out when you think
about historic parades from past years
you know what came to mind very quickly
was that jason kelsey's speech from
from a few years ago and it was
profanity laced and he worried about
about what management thought of it but
it fit philadelphia perfectly we wrote
like three or four or five stories just
on jason kelsey's speech and the impact
it left in philadelphia that to me was
the most
meaningful speech i think i've ever
heard at one of these parades normally
it's stuff like we saw today but jason
kelsey's was really good
yeah in the mummer's outfit uh which
he looked like he was the guy who was
deciding
whether or not people got past the gates
of oz
and uh it was quite a costume that has
yet to be duplicated
and and was unprecedented when he did it
i
you know there are little things that
flash for me anytime someone tries to
sing you try to both remember and forget
that
i remember art model dancing at the
super bowl 35
celebration and that was a sight to see
but it it's
always alcohol fueled it's always a
little over the top
it's always aspirational they're always
ready to come back for more
no champion ever says that's it for us
see you later it was fun we're going
back to seven and nine next year
but look the reality is the chances
are uh much greater that the buccaneers
won't
be back in the super bowl then that they
will but with tom brady
that changes everything because he's
been so men in so many of them and has
now
won seven of them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports